well we had met each other over the
years
in passing a few times lots of mutual
friends yeah and he always forgot me
and I would be reintroducing myself like
is this guy for real and then we got
cast in a movie together and we were
both going through very difficult times
in our lives both going through breakups
it was like a very tumultuous time yeah
um you were late for the table reads
only two hours later two hours later for
the table read yeah it was bad so he
came to this table read and introduced
himself again
and I said a month and a half ago we
co-hosted a actors brunch at Sundance
with like five other actors but still a
small group I showed him a picture of us
standing together
um